good evening and welcome to Washington
i'm shannon bream in for bret baier
First Lady Melania Trump was with her
husband the president this afternoon for
a briefing about the hurricane season
earlier in the day the president
unleashed a rhetorical hurricane ripping
into the media for its coverage of his
wife this afternoon the president was in
a forgiving mood chief White House
correspondent Don Roberts has that for
us tonight good evening John Shannon
good evening to you a White House
official tells Fox News that the recent
spate of presidential Pardons and
commutations is just the beginning that
President Trump is actively considering
another half dozen with dozens more
being reviewed by White House staff we
had a season last year like no other in
terms of the power the level two
hurricanes the fires along the west
coast President Trump at FEMA
headquarters today for his annual
briefing on the upcoming hurricane
season but it was his powers of
presidential pardon that took center
stage today the White House announcing
President Trump is commuting the
sentence of Alice Marie Johnson last
week Kim Kardashian called on the
President to ask him to pardon Johnson a
great-grandmother who has been jailed
since 1996 and a nonviolent drug charge
while the commutation fell short of a
full pardon the White House praised
Johnson's rehabilitation in a statement
saying Ms Johnson has accepted
responsibility for her past behavior and
has been a model prisoner over the past
two decades I'd like to sort of maybe
say and pay some respects to some of the
people here today I have a list of
course we have to start with our great
first lady Melania at the president's
side today during the FEMA briefing
first lady Melania Trump the first time
she has been seen on camera since a
medical procedure May 14th but she's
doing great
we're very proud of what she's done a
fantastic job as first lady the people
love you people of our country love you
thank you honey
the first lady was out of public view
for 22 days prompting speculation and
many media outlets that something was
amiss ahead of today's appearance
president drop hammering the speculation
tweeting the fake news media has been so
unfair and vicious to my wife in our
Great First Lady Melania during her
recovery from surgery they reported
everything from near death to facelift
to left the White House and me for New
York or Virginia to abuse all fake she
is doing really well secretary Nielsen
what do I say about you President Trump
today also spreading a little love
around for cabinet members on the front
lines of disaster response and throwing
a big bone to his embattled EPA
Administrator Scott Pruett administrator
Scott Pruett
thank you Scott very much EPA is doing
really really well and you know somebody
has to say that about you a little bit
you know that Scott Pruett long under
scrutiny for lavish spending and
security demands was most recently under
fire for asking an aide to contact
chick-fil-a about a possible franchise
for his wife and for asking an aide to
look into whether he could buy a used
mattress from the Trump International
Hotel people are really impressed with
the job that's being done at the EPA
thank you very much Scott today two top
aides to prune at the EPA announced that
they were resigning Mellon hop who is
the aid that Pruitt asked to try to
procure the used mattress from the Trump
Hotel announced as she is going to be
leaving on Friday according to published
reports Huck got tired of Pruett
throwing her under the bus and seeing
her name in print the other official to
be leaving is reportedly Sarah Greenwald
top attorney there and one of Pruitt's
closest advisors both Greenwald and Huck
were at the center of the recent
controversy over pay increases at the
EPA that ran afoul of White House
guidelines
Shannon John Roberts live for us at the
White House thank you John